[Musique]
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france bienvenue pour deux heures
d'émission nous décrypterons comme
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 29 juin le
variant valtat devient progressivement
dominant france selon olivier ferrand il
représente 20% des cathos vide
le ministre de la santé qui se veut
toutefois rassurant on peut y échapper
avec la vaccination est un traçage serré
si une quatrième vague n'est pas à
exclure elle pourrait être différente
des précédentes
outre-atlantique le variant delta
représentent environ 35% des quatre co
vide si le nombre de nouvelles
infections stagne aux états unis il
existe un fort contraste entre les
régions plus ou moins vacciner
la maison blanche elle avait concédé la
semaine dernière que l'objectif fixé par
le président joe biden pour le 4 juillet
jour de la fête de l'indépendance ne
serait pas atteint
[Musique]
en amérique du sud à présent le brésil
menacé par une troisième vague le pays
est le deuxième le plus meurtri par la
pandémie et des pleurs plus de cinq cent
mille morts les services de santé sont
saturés et le président paul sonar ou de
plus en contre et kike pour sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
ils représentent désormais 20% des cas
de covile 19 en france le variant delta
poursuit sa progression dans le pays
selon olivier ferrand et ce alors que la
phase iii du déconfinement approche
un nouveau protocole sanitaire en
entreprise entrera lui en vigueur le 1er
juillet pour plus de précision on
retrouve tout de suite et stéphane
directe du ministère de la santé
bonsoir estelle que doit-on retenir dans
de ce nouveau protocole eh bien on va
commencer à parler changement stéphanie
d'abord la fin des juges dans les
restaurants d'entreprise alors que le
protocole précédent prévoyait six
chaises maximum autour des tables le
nouveau document indique seulement que
le salarié doit disposer d'une place
assise du côté des dépôts comme par
exemple lé pot de départ le ministère du
travail recommande et qu'il soit
toujours organisés en extérieur mais là
encore pas de nombreux maximum de
personnes préconisent et jusqu'à présent
elle c'était 25 personnes maximum
sur le front de la vaccination le
ministère demande aux entreprises et
qu'elles facilitent l'accès à la
vaccination aux salariés autrement dit
qu'elle les autorise à s'absenter
pendant leurs heures de travail pour
qu'ils aillent se faire vacciner tout en
précisant que ceux qui le souhaitent se
rapprochent de leur employeur afin
d'organiser au mieux cette absence pas
de changement en revanche du côté du
télétravail il reste encouragé lorsqu'il
est possible et le gouvernement
préconise deux jours de télétravail par
semaine car ce dispositif est toujours
considérée comme l'une des mesures
elle est plus elle est efficace pour
pour contenir lé risque d'infection au
cosy 19 et celle ce nouveau protocole
prévoit donc un allègement des
restrictions et ce alors que le variant
d'un taille considéré comme plus
contagieux et qu'il devient
progressivement dominant mais rien n'est
encore joué a précisé olivier ferrand
oui exactement mon petit échappé a
indiqué à le ministre de la santé
comment tu es bien avec la vaccination
est un traçage est serré à l'image de ce
qui a été fait dans les landes c'est
dans ce département que le variant
d'état delta est apparue en premier la
balle
le gouvernement a amené un plan d'action
est très fort s'est félicité olivier
ferrand alors pour lui pas question de
baisser les bras car le taux est d'un
synode incidences continuent de baisser
y compris dans ce département alors en
cas de quatrième vague notamment à
l'automne le ministre a estimé que la
situation serait cette fois différente
en des précédentes en raison notamment
de la vaccination pour lui selon lui le
vaccin réduit de 94 à 95% les
hospitalisations et les formes sévères
du virus mais pour olivier ferrand le
problème ce sont ceux qui hésitent et
qui retarde la vaccination car ils sont
je cite particulièrement exposé un
invariant particulièrement contagieux et
justement olivier ferrand a menacé de
rendre la vaccination obligatoire pour
les soignants en septembre si je cite le
travail de conviction n'a pas été
suffisant durant l'été estelle le
variant d'attaqué justement en dehors de
la france devient progressivement
majoritaire dans beaucoup de pays c'est
le cas de l'australie du royaume uni et
de la russie saint-pétersbourg qui va
d'ailleurs accueillir les quarts de
finale
de l'euro de football oui et le quart de
finale aura lieu comme prévu c'est ce
qu'a indiqué le comité d'organisation de
l'euro à saint pétersbourg à nos
confrères de la fp rien ne changera donc
pour le match qui opposera est la suisse
à l'espagne vendredi sachez que
l'allemagne a fermé à ses frontières aux
voyageurs en provenance de russie et du
portugal notamment le ministre allemand
des sports et qui a demandé au
gouvernement britannique ainsi qu'à lui
et à l'uefa de réduire le nombre de
supporteurs présents dans le stade de
wembley à londres c'est là que se
joueront à les derniers matches de
l'euro et notamment est la finale
déclarations du ministre des sports
allemand qui est intervenue avant la
rencontre allemagne angleterre qui a a
commencé ce soir à 18 heures dans le
stade de wembley justement c'est terminé
et c'est léo le ministre de la santé
allemand peut se rassurer n'y aura pas
beaucoup d'allemands manifestement aux
quarts de finale puisqu'ils ont été
éliminés par l'angleterre voilà mercier
stèle farges en direct donc du ministère
de la santé
et c'est donc une course contre la
montre qui est enclenchée par les
pouvoirs publics pour convaincre les
récalcitrants à la vaccination en france
mais aussi à l'étranger
l'objectif est d'éviter une potentielle
quatrième vague cet été qui entraînerait
peut-être 1re confinement alors question
la vaccination comment contraindre sans
la force et c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec vous
nommez garbade chef du service
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bonsoir à vous sabrina délits
qu'on fondatrice du cercle des proches
aidants en ehpad dans soir à vous aussi
merci d'être là enfin philippe
vayssettes président de la fédération
des syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
bonsoir à vous aussi merci d'être avec
nous alors d'à peine 10 % le variant
delta représente donc désormais 20% des
cas de komi diagnostiqués en france
selon le ministre de la santé
mais on petit échapper même si c'est une
progression plutôt fulgurante philippe
vayssettes vous êtes inquiet par ces
chiffres ou vous partager le diagnostic
plutôt rassurant d'olivier veyrat oui on
le diagnostic de lévis verrons il est
fondé sur l'idée que tout le monde va
finir par comprendre qu'il faut se faire
vacciner et donc nous savons maintenant
les deux enfin nous avons les soignant
suffisant d'heures suffisant pour
vacciner
nous avons donc eu toute la logistique
qui maintenant permet d'avoir sans
attente la possibilité de se faire
vacciner
donc il faut vraiment que tout le monde
vienne se faire vacciner est comme ça
nous serons enfin débarrassé de cette
problématique virale enfin c'est du bon
sens et oui je suis d'accord avec le
ministre à partir du moment où on est
vacciné contre lacko vie des biens et
nous aurons la possibilité
j'espère d'avoir une quatrième vague qui
peut être arrivera mais ne fera pas de
dégâts et d'une embolie sera pas nos
hôpitaux et qui est surtout surtout pour
les gens parce que tout le monde connaît
maintenant dans ses proches qui sont qui
ont une intubation qui sont en
réanimation n'auront pas vivre ce
calvaire
bruno robert herrmann vous vous partagez
ce diagnostic de philippe besset et
et d'olivier ferrand oui on peut encore
y échapper grâce à la vaccination et
grâce au traçage philippe a b c est
plutôt optimiste en disant les gens vont
finir par comprendre qu'il faut se
vacciner c'est votre avis aussi
alors si vous voulez le variant delta va
inéluctablement remplacer les autres
variantes donc d'ici la fin de l'été
la quasi-totalité des variantes qui vont
circuler sur le territoire seront liés à
ce variant delta c'est quelque chose qui
ne dépend pas de nous c'est lié à la
sélection des russes entre eux
maintenant effectivement comme ça a été
dit l'ensemble des vaccins dont nous
disposons sont parfaitement efficace
pour protéger contre les formes graves
et des formes mortelles de lakovic 19 et
compris celles liées à tous les variants
dont le variant delta il faut donc
évidemment se protéger à l'échelle
individuelle pour ne pas faire une forme
grave et mourir et par ailleurs il faut
vacciner le plus grand nombre pour
réduire la circulation du virus et
protéger les quelques personnes qui
n'auraient pas été vaccinés et donc
évidemment je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit ainsi que la
stratégie aujourd'hui pour permettre en
septembre d'éviter un rebond hospitalier
des infections liées à la copie de 19 et
probablement en rapport avec le variant
delta il faut vacciner le maximum de
personnes
et bien si il faut surtout vacciner la
totalité des personnes adultes à risque
de faire des formes graves
c'est la seule solution est la seule
solution sauf qu'on parle beaucoup en ce
moment de ce fameux plafond de verre de
la vaccination en france mais aussi à
l'étranger
il faut que les soignants se fassent
vacciner a redit olivier verront 50 %
seulement de soignants en ehpad 1 sont
vaccinés
ça pourrait devenir obligatoire si jugés
insuffisants en septembre a dit le
ministre de la santé sabrina délit
vous êtes pour pour cette vaccination
contrainte en septembre notamment dans
les ehpad ans est pour vous la question
évidemment et est primordial un bien sûr
bien sûr nous aujourd'hui dire qu'on est
pauvre qu'on est contre mon déplore tout
d'abord qu'il faille d'une obligation
vaccinale pour contraindre les soignants
à se faire vacciner et notamment les
soigner en ehpad qui travaille auprès de
personnes âgées particulièrement
vulnérables particulièrement fragile
donc nous surtout voudrait que ces
soignants se mettent un point notre
place à nous famille quand le virus est
arrivé on a enfermé nos parents on les a
complètement de l'autre et ça pose des
problèmes à personne contiennent les
familles à l'écart où nous et
l'isolément par an ça n'a posé de
problème à personne nous tenait tout
autre discours
on fait ça pour protéger les non
résidents à ce moment là c'est encore
leurs résidents s'étaient tues nos
parents hélas aujourd'hui ils ont la
possibilité puisque c'est pas que le
directeur qui décide tout son
établissement en ouvert les portes de
fermer les formats protocole c'est
chacun chaque soignant peut décider par
lui-même
hélas aujourd'hui ont une grosse
réticence moi je trouve ça vraiment
dommage d'autant que aujourd'hui vous
avez quand même des directeurs d'ehpad
qui vous dise
havel si telle ou telle famille n'est
pas vaccinée vous ne pouvez pas accéder
en temps chambre vous ne pourra pas
retrouver une vie normale
tant qu'on n'aura pas atteint une bulle
d'immunité de 75% à peu près surtout
l'ehpad donc avec 90 95 % des résidents
matinée on n'y arrivera jamais si on
avec un taux aussi bas
le soignant n'est pas vaccinée donc nous
on déplore je voudrais tout simplement
pour tout bon conte et cette bulle de
protection aussi bien pour les résidents
du pour les soignants les fans religieux
ou 5 beaucoup à vous êtes fait vacciner
mais c'est pas suffisant peut pas tout
faire il faut qu'on avance ensemble
philippe besset c'est vrai qu'en italie
on a écarté les soignants qui ne
viennent pas se faire vacciner au texas
par exemple ils sont suspendus on a
beaucoup parlé de déontologie
que c'est une faute morale un pont pour
certains observateurs de dettes
soignants et notamment dans les ehpad et
de ne pas être vaccinés votre opinion là
dessus est ce qu'il faut tout simplement
la rendre obligatoire et ne pas
tergiverser ne pas avoir la main qui
tremble à la rentrée si si le chiffre
n'est pas assez suffisant pour les
soignants oui c'est assez clair on a dit
suffisamment mais c'était une obligation
déontologique le ministre laisse encore
deux mois les mois d'été à tout le monde
pour prendre ses responsabilités et 6
hors de question pour enseignants de
mettre la vie des patients dont il a la
charge en danger donc oui si jamais si
jamais à la fin de l'été et bien on ne
tient pas un chiffre qui atteint 80 à
90% comme les résidents des ehpad
il faudra passer par la fin de
l'obligation cycle est alors ça variant
delta en tout cas il inquiète évidemment
le monde entier on le disait tout à
l'heure un l'australie le royaume uni le
portugal ou encore la russie où ça se
passe pas très bien en ce moment moscou
justement le maire sergueï sobianine a
fait un point sur sur cette épidémie est
coté les situations à moscou reste très
difficile
quant au nombre de nouveaux cas
identifiés de co vide on reste à peu
près au même niveau mais c'est un niveau
très élevé le niveau record de toutes
les périodes principal le nombre
d'hospitalisations a augmenté et celui
des lieux occupés à moscou est proche de
15 mille le nombre de morts dans des
hôpitaux a également augmenté depuis la
semaine dernière
ça c'est pour planter le décor alors
qu'on le rappelle la réussite est le
premier à avoir son bac sans mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une vraie défiance de la
population vers la vaccination les
autorités de la capitale russe qui ont
adopté plusieurs mesures qui s'apparente
il faut bien le dire une forme de
vaccination obligatoire pour aller au
restaurant pour se faire soigner à
l'hôpital il faut être vaccinés à moscou
clairement bruno mega man looks est un
grand défenseur de la vaccination ce
qu'il faut faire la même chose en france
écoutez on veut dire pour le moment
encore
nous n'avons pas atteint ce fameux
plafond il est très probable que nous
l'atteignons rapidement aux environs de
65% de primo vacciner comme dans les
autres pays aux états unis en israël
effectivement à ce moment là il faudra
voir si un septembre il y à une
recirculation importante du virus
il faudra très probablement on va dire
contre 1 de la population à choisir la
vaccination et les moyens à disposition
sont d'abord l'instauration du pass
sanitaires dans les activités
quotidiennes et le second très
probablement comme suggéré par
l'académie de médecine c'est le
déremboursement des tests pcr fait pour
convenances personnelles ou pour raison
de voyages ce sont deux mesures certes
difficile mais qui permettront à ceux
qui ne sont pas vaccinés d'être mis face
à leurs responsabilités effectivement il
serait hasardeux voire dangereux que des
personnes prennent des risques d'abord
pour eux mêmes et engendre des coûts
pour la société ensuite mettre en danger
d'autres personnes notamment évidemment
lorsqu'on travaille en ehpad faire
introduire un virus dans un ehpad y
compris lorsque la très grosse majorité
des pensionnaires sont vaccinés vacciner
fait prendre malgré tout un risque de
décès directs de personnes et donc
effectivement il faut absolument se
faire vacciner dans ces circonstances
sabrina avait guéri on imagine que vous
avez eus ces conversations c'est tout se
retrouver à table
voilà et l'opinion évidemment de 2
chacun est libre et c'est un débat
compliqué de deux personnes qui ne
souhaitent pas se faire vacciner
vous vous êtes pour ce genre voilà deux
mesures un peu peut-être hypocrite pour
certains parce que si on commence à
faire payer au lait les pcr si on on a
interdit aux gens voilà deux voyages et
d'aller dans les restaurants et bien les
gens seront obligés d'aller se faire
vacciner vous vous êtes pour justement
vous parce qu on imagine que vous vos
contraintes elles sont évidemment pas du
ressort du confort vous avez envie de
voir vos proches dans les ehpad et c'est
bien normal
oui tout à fait et pour ceux qui sont
pas décidés
des proches aidants en ehpad sur notre
petit groupe un petit noyau de départ on
a quand même deux mamans et un papa qui
se ment récemment donc on a eu beaucoup
de décès est vraiment le petit groupe
initial ça peut pas continuer comme ça
on sait que majoritairement c'est le
personnel qui fait rentrer un maximum
qui fait rentrer le virus va vous moi en
ehpad auprès nos parents attention je ne
les convainc pas je les plains pas ils
ont dit oui
donc ils peuvent avoir le virus beaucoup
sont jeunes peuvent être asymptomatique
mais leur travail c'est de travailler
avec et aux côtés de personnes fragiles
donc ils se doivent de les protéger
aujourd'hui moi je suis encore jeune je
suis vacciné je suis vacciné d'autres
familles on se tait pas tout de suite
pour retrouver leurs parents
aujourd'hui après l'année l'année et
demi qu'on a vécu de cauchemar tout sens
mais tous sur le même plan mais en
particulier les résidents des packs qui
ont été enfermés c'était vraiment une
personne ne peut pas nous dire au bout
d'un an et demi on entrevoit le bout du
tunnel pour convenance personnelle
moi j'ai pas envie de faire vacciner je
ferai des tests ont arrêté un soignant
n'est pas ne va pas de se faire tester
trois fois où toutes les 72 heures ou
trois fois par semaine car dont donc
aujourd'hui oui la vaccination nous
semble la réponse adéquate et je pense
en effet que il est dommage qu'on soit
obligé d'arriver à contraindre les
soigner en particulier et la population
en général et que ça devrait être un
geste citoyen pour s'en sortir et puis
il ya un an semble s'en sortir vraiment
pour nous tous philippe besset c'est un
débat délicat parce que des anti vaccins
voilà on en connaît tous et c'est une
opinion qui est répandue et qui se
respecte
à côté de cela on écoute
lester du pasteur je vous propose
d'écouter de réagir après les personnes
non vaccinées contribuer de façon
disproportionnée à la transmission une
personnes non vaccinées à douze fois
plus de risque de transmettre le sar
skov 2 qu'une personne vaccinée en
l'absence de mesures de contrôle un pic
de spécialisation comparable à celui de
l'automne 2020 pourraient être observés
visant principalement les non vaccinés
voilà pour le constat philippe besset
qu'est ce que vous dites ces gens qui
ont peur du vaccin qui ont peut-être pas
confiance quand on voit cette donne est
tout simplement une personne vaccinée
qui a douze fois plus de risque de
transmettre le virus à on met enfin
c'est si les philosophes ont répondu à
la question la liberté de chacun
s'arrête où commence celle de l'autre
il est question de collectivités il est
question de l'arrêt de la façon dont
nadon on vit dans une collectivité
ce nom a envie de vivre tout seul dans
son appartement ma foi au grand bien
fasse à ce qui va vivre tout seul mais à
partir du moment où on met par son
comportement la vie des autres en danger
ce n'est plus possible en fait je n'ai
plus c'est ça qui n'est plus aussi donc
c'est une obligation pour ma part j'ai
toujours considéré comme déontologie
mais ça ne peuvent absolument aucun
problème qu'elle devienne légal si si si
ça doit être levé 6 7 2 6 1 doit être
mais ça devrait pas être devrait être
même pas être sûr de sûr de ce débat
cette affaire tout le monde quand il dit
dans une collectivité surtout avec des
personnes à risque ne devrait se faire
vacciner sans se poser de questions
aussi claire on vraiment très
contrariant d'avoir des bateaux
il ya quelque chose d'autre qui enquête
en ce moment et là la collectivité joue
à fond c'est l'euro de foot évidemment
cette compétition on a vu que dd et 300
supporters avaient été testés positifs
hier ils sont rentrés de finlande la
semaine
dernière je vous propose avant de faire
réagir bruno megaman d'écouter le
ministre allemand de l'intérieur sur ce
sujet je trouve cela irresponsable que
des dizaines de milliers de gens se
rassemblent sur des espaces étroits dans
des pays classés à risque à cause du
très contagieux variant delta comme cela
est le cas actuellement en angleterre
dénommé gardanne je m'adresse évidemment
médecin que vous n'êtes quand vous voyez
ces stades remplis de monde à nouveau qu
est ce que vous vous dites c'est
totalement irresponsable comme le dit le
ministre allemand oui tout à fait on va
dire il faut être effectivement
extrêmement prudents aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de pays ont été
identifiés en rouge comme étant encore
avec une circulation virale importante
une prévalence élevée du variant delta
ça serait dommage évidemment de s'y
rendre de ne pas prendre de précautions
et de ramener le virus avec soin en
france et de faire naître en cluster ça
vaut dix cher le fait d'assister à un
match de foot il faut bien sûr être
prudents respectez toutes les
recommandations émises par les autorités
sanitaires
et malheureusement au vu des
circonstances actuelles accepter que
peut-être regarder un match chez soi
devant la télévision et finalement le
mieux pour la collectivité
merci en tout cas tous les 3 bruno
ménard vannes sabrina des mairies et
philippe besset d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france le passé ni terre
européens entrent en vigueur ce jeudi
objectif faciliter les déplacements à et
relancer le tourisme au sein de l'union
européenne
elle les détails en bref et en images
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlons de la situation sanitaire
aux états unis où le variant delta
représente également 35% des quatre co
vide le patronat américain réclame à
l'administration byden la réouverture
des frontières ou aux européens aient
les touristes aussi et puis direction le
brésil qui compte plus de 60 mille décès
luogo ville le président vol sonar ou
pourrait être rattrapé par une affaire
suspect d'achat de vaccins
[Musique]
assiste-t-on à une soviétisation de
l'économie c'est simplement une place de
plus en plus prépondérante de l'état
aujourd'hui avec les prêts garantis par
l'état et c'est fait
l'état se paye les entreprises l'état
pourrait devenir un partenaire un
actionnaire d'outré un très grand nombre
d'entreprises françaises
on a un peu dans une logique d'économie
de guerre où l'état a suppléé on va dire
à la défaillance du privé on est dans
quelque chose qui ressemble à une
soviétisation il est vrai que le
gouvernement n'avait aujourd'hui pas
d'autre moyen que de faire le poids
qu'il en coûte
l'état aujourd'hui aide tout et
n'importe quoi et c'est bien le problème
qui va soutenir va pas va subir ça c'est
nous dans nos impôts
le terme banlieue voir le terme cité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai
qu'ils les médias ont un regard on va
dire assez particulier des banlieues et
qui dérange aujourd'hui et en donne
scénarisation de la banlieue ça se
résoudrait cas des jeunes violents
contre une police tout ce qu'elle son
travail c'est plus compliqué que ça on
est français on est fiers de vivre dans
ces quartiers même si à des difficultés
et la moindre des choses c'est
d'inscrire aussi notre empreinte canton
quand on participe à la vie de la
société et malheureusement n'y a pas
cette reconnaissance aujourd'hui je
pense que le changement viendra d'abord
à travers cette conscientisation des
citoyens des quartiers populaires on
parle également des deux zones de
reconquête républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis que le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers ont été compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rexy le vrai
sujet c'est celui de faire dialoguer les
douaniers français les poignées
britannique est ce qui m'inquiète dans
le bric site c'est pas le break 6 et la
bureaucratie du brics comment ça va se
passer par exemple pour l'été qui arrive
la côte d'azur verra peu ou pas
d'anglais je suspecte effectivement le
gouvernement britannique d'essayer de
convaincre les britanniques de rester en
grande bretagne pour faciliter la
relance de l'économie britannique par
rapport à la crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit
il n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autorités assez
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inouï tg les gens ne s'étaient des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez le variant
delta on le disait qu'il progresse un
peu partout direction maintenant les
états unis où il représente 35% des
quatre copines détectés depuis le 16
juin le nombre d'infections se stabilise
et aussi entre 11000 et douze mille cas
recensés chaque jour pour plus de
précision on retrouve notre reporter
thomas bonnin en direct de washington
un bon soir thomas à quelle est
exactement la situation sanitaire aux
états unis parce que c'est vrai que ici
en france on en parle moins en ce moment
bonsoir stéphanie alors ici il ya une
inquiétude également autour de ce fameux
variant delta il serait responsable
aujourd'hui d'une contamination sur 5
sur l'ensemble du territoire mais il ya
assez peu de doute sur le fait que ce
variant finira par être majoritaires ici
aux etats unis les autorités sanitaires
estiment qu'elles ont entre un et deux
mois de retard sur la situation
britannique il surveille donc très
attentivement ce qu'il se passe au
royaume uni le prévoit notamment les
modèles pour bien suivre la situation en
britannique pour voir ce qui pourrait
être évitée ici aux etats unis
l'autre inquiétude elle concerne la
couverture vaccinale sur l'ensemble du
territoire aujourd'hui il ya 46 % de la
population américaine qui est totalement
vacciner et ce chiffre n'est pas
suffisant selon les autorités sanitaires
là encore pour complètement mettre un
terme à cette pandémie deux commis 19 et
puis surtout il y à de très fortes
disparités entre les états on sait que
sur les côtes est et ouest des états
unis
globalement la population est très
largement vacciner mais en revanche dans
les étapes plus ruraux ou dans les états
du sud du pays
on arrive à des chiffres bien inférieurs
je prends l'exemple de l'arkansas et en
arkansas
seuls 34% de la population est à ce jour
vacciner on sait que l'objectif de joe
biden ne sera donc pas tenus le
président américain avait fixé la date
du 4 juillet dimanche prochain jour de
la fête nationale américaine
avec un objectif 70 % de la population
américaine qui aurait reçu au moins une
dose de vaccin on n'arrivera pas à cet
objectif qui serait atteint qui sera
atteint probablement quelques semaines
plus tard alors malgré tout joe biden
continue d'encourager les américains à
se faire vacciner il était en caroline
du nord il ya quelques jours justement
pour délivrer ce message il dit vouloir
un été sans kobe d'un été à festif
écoutez le président des états unis joe
biden donc en caroline du nord
ce variant delta est plus facilement
transmissible potentiellement plus
mortelle est particulièrement dangereux
pour les jeunes les jeunes dr anthony
fauci
et que c'est la plus grande menace pour
notre combat contre le coc u19 la bonne
nouvelle c'est que nous avons une
solution
la science
en appel la meilleure façon de se
protéger contre le virus et ses
variantes et de se faire vacciner
complètement l'émergence de ce variant
delta et l'inquiétude qu'ils suscitent
conduit en tout cas certaines autorités
locales à prendre des mesures a imposé
de nouvelles restrictions il ya par
exemple le comté de los angeles qui
recommande désormais très vivement à ses
habitants de porter le masque en
intérieur y compris les américains qui
ont été vaccinés on sait pourtant qu'il
ya quelques semaines maintenant le port
du masque n'est plus obligatoire ici en
intérieur et bien voilà des autorités
locales qui commence à reprendre des
mesures il ya donc une très forte
inquiétude
autre conséquence de ces indicateurs
sanitaires qui ne sont pas bons le plus
en plus maintenant de politiques
encouragent les plus jeunes à se faire
vacciner notamment en vue de la rentrée
des classes qui dans certains états aura
lieu à dès le mois d'août prochain il
n'y a pas encore de décision sur le fait
que le port du masque soit rendue
obligatoire dans les salles de classe
c'est un débat qui a lieu en ce moment
et il sera tranché très localement vous
savez ici que les décisions sont prises
à l'échelle d'un état parfois même d'un
comté autre conséquence de toutes ces
inquiétudes et bien c'est la réouverture
des frontières qui tarde
on sait que les américains ont le droit
eux de se rendre en europe pour voyager
mais il n'y a pas de réciprocité les
européens ont toujours interdiction
d'entrer sur le territoire américain
sans motif impérieux
certains avaient espéré que le voyage de
joe biden et de son secrétaire d'état
anthony blinken en europe puisse
conduire à des annonces en ce sens il
n'en a rien été et même les frontières
terrestres des états unis que ce soit
avec le canada ou avec le mexique
resteront fermés au moins jusqu'au 21
juillet prochain
il y avait un certain nombre d'acteurs
économiques qui presse le gouvernement a
levé ses restrictions parce qu'on sait
que cette fermeture de frontières a un
impact considérable pour un certain
nombre d'acteurs économiques de la
région
il ya aussi un aspect politique
évidemment dans cette crise sanitaire
vous avez des médias américains qui font
un parallèle en ce moment entre eux à
l'épée les états où la vaccination est
faible avec les états qui ont le plus
voté pour donald trump il met en
parallèle le nombre de personnes non
vaccinées dans certains
comptez dans des états ruraux et le
nombre de personnes qui ont voté pour
donald trump
lors de la dernière élection
présidentielle comme pour a expliqué que
peut-être parmi les plus réfractaires se
trouverait finalement des électeurs de
l'ancien président pourtant on sait que
donald trump lui est plutôt pro
vaccination il avait même acheté
beaucoup doses à l'époque au début de la
pandémie même si ces derniers jours il
faut dire qu'il a montré quelques
réserves notamment sur la vaccination
des plus jeunes il ya donc comme dans
d'autres pays une défiance vis-à-vis de
la parole officielle ici aux etats unis
un certain nombre de réfractaires qui ne
veulent toujours pas se faire vacciner
et une personne incarne justement cette
défiance de la parole officielle c'est
le docteur anthony fauci le conseiller
santé de la maison blanche qui est la
cible de critiques très vives depuis
plusieurs semaines maintenant
depuis que des mails ont été publiées
dans des médias américains et que
certains estiment qu'il tient un
discours complètement différent en
public qu'en privé voilà donc ce qui
porte pouces a alimenté la défiance de
certains américains donc pour la
vaccination est ce qui conduit les
autorités ici aux etats-unis à avoir une
très forte inquiétude joe biden avait
dit vouloir faire de la lutte contre la
pandémie
la priorité de son mandat force est de
constater qu'il reste encore du travail
à faire pour le président américain
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et en russie un également un
triste record 150 hermine malades du
commises actuellement hospitalisées
selon le ministre de la santé le payer
plus que jamais confrontés aux variants
delta tout de suite les correspondances
de vera goffman à moscou il sera
impossible d'atteindre le chiffre de 60%
de vaccination dans la population avant
l'automne
initialement prévue par les autorités a
affirmé le porte parole du kremlin
dmitri peskov
bien que le produit était accessible la
dynamique de vaccination a été jusqu'ici
à un niveau assez faible la tendance
vient de changer et espère le kremlin va
persister
écoutez évidemment nous n'arriverons pas
à vacciner 60 % de la population
nous constatons que ce n'est que cette
semaine que le nombre de personnes
souhaitant se faire vacciner a commencé
plus ou moins augmenté
avant la dynamique de vaccination était
malheureusement à un niveau faible
alors que toutes les opportunités pour
cela été créée par l'état
dieu merci actuellement de plus en plus
de citoyens font preuve de conscience
espérons donc que cette dynamique
persistera mais bien sûr il est évident
que ce niveau de vaccination ne sera pas
atteint par conséquent bien sûr les
délais seront reportés quant à la
situation à moscou épicentre de
l'épidémie en russie elle reste
extrêmement difficile à cause du nombre
très élevé des hospitalisations dues à
la propagation du baril entre delta ii
coronavirus selon le maire de la
capitale sergey se baignent les
autorités font face à des chiffres
record pour le grâce aux exigences
imposées dans le secteur des services
est relative à l'accès aux services de
restauration rapide quelle histoire
le nombre de personnes inscrites à la
vaccination a considérablement augmenté
au cours de la semaine dernière
atteignant 87 mille personnes par jour
n'est zapper ce bestiau là c'est un
niveau très très élevé la situation à
moscou reste très difficile au calysto
mou et où les neuf cantons nombre de
nouveaux cas identifiés de co vide on
reste à peu près au même niveau mais
c'est un niveau très élevé le niveau
record de toutes les périodes principal
a lâché en période plus longue spéciale
c'est le nombre d'hospitalisations a
augmenté celui d'ailier occupé à moscou
est proche de 15000 nantes est 7e à
khalis ans le nombre de morts dans les
hôpitaux a également augmenté depuis la
semaine dernière bosse plus de vingt
mille nouveaux cas de coronavirus ont
été détectés aujourd'hui dans 85 régions
russes dont plus de 6000 à moscow le
nombre des décès et en os 6 152 morts
dans le pays dont 121 de la capitale en
dernières 24 heures elle amena soit du
variant delta qui planent également sur
l'australie brisbane devient la
quatrième grande ville à se confiner
pour trois jours
le pays continent enregistre un regain
d'affection au covin cyrielle boe avec
robert puech les confinements se
multiplient à compter de ce mardi soir
environ 10 millions d'australiens sont
soumis un confinement dans plusieurs
grandes villes du pays
après sydney darwin ou encore perth
c'est au tour de la ville de brisbane
dans l'état du queensland de serrer la
vis
le risque est réel et nous devons agir
rapidement nous devons agir avec force
nous devons agir vite
nous devons faire ça pendant trois jours
il y aura donc un confinement pendant
trois jours et je ne veux pas que ce
soit 30 jours
donc nous devons juste faire ça à partir
de 18h ce soir jusqu'à vendredi 18h le
sud est du queensland townsville à palm
island et magnetic island seront
confinés à brisbane comme dans les
autres villes du pays le port du masque
a été rendue obligatoire tout comme la
limitation des rassemblements en
extérieur les autorités locales tentent
de freiner le variant delta qui circule
activement dans le pays
en renforcement des restrictions
sanitaires acceptée par certains
australiens
tout le monde joue et les uns près des
autres sans porter de masque
je me suis dit que c'était juste absurde
qu'on en finisse avec ça le plus vite
possible mais ça n'en prendra pas la
direction si les gens n'écoutent pas
lorsqu'il ya un pic qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre
il n'y a pas grand chose que l'on puisse
faire donc mieux vaut prévenir que
guérir
la situation dans le queensland est
ailleurs dans le pays a poussé le
premier ministre australien scott
morrison à rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour les personnels
s'occupant de personnes âgées ou
travaillant dans des sites de mise en
quarantaine depuis le début de la
pandémie le gouvernement australien est
régulièrement critiqué notamment pour la
lenteur de sa campagne de vaccination à
ce jour 7,4 millions de doses de vaccin
ont été administrées dans le pays mais
moins de 5% des australiens ont reçu
leurs deux injections permanisés la
situation sanitaire est également
inquiétant depuis un mois les malaisiens
sont strictement confiner leurs
événements
d'être prolongé pour une durée indéfinie
mehdi et ce qui est fier avec grégoire
douce et des rues désertes depuis le
début du mois de juin
ces images pourrait encore perdurer
durant des semaines
en cause un regain de l'épidémie en
malaisie une augmentation du nombre
d'infections de l'ordre de 5000 nouveaux
cas par jour en moyenne et des dizaines
de morts
cette prolongation de la mise sous
cloche oblige les entreprises à réduire
leurs activités
les commerçants en redoute les
conséquences il n'y a personne qui vient
acheter des produits
nous gérons notre commerce nos portes
restent ouvertes
mais il n'y a aucun client c'est très
difficile en ce moment
avant la pandémie je pouvais gagner une
centaine d'euros par jour mais
actuellement c'est même difficile de
gagner 20 euros
les autorités malaisiennes qui redoute
la saturation des établissements
hospitaliers ont posé des conditions à
la levée du confinement
parmi celles ci l'objectif de moins de
4000 nouveaux cas quotidiens et celui
d'avoir au moins 10% de la population
vaccinée pour le moment uniquement 6 %
des habitants ont complété leur parcours
vaccinale une partie d'entre eux
approuvent la stratégie du gouvernement
j'approuve le confinement car le premier
ministre a dit que si le nombre de cas
ne descendait pas en dessous de 4000 le
confinement ne prendra pas fin cela va
encourager les gens à plus s'impliquer
pour atteindre cet objectif en restant à
la maison et en observant tout le reste
je sais qu'il ya des gens qui ne peuvent
pas gagner leur vie à cause du
confinement mais à mon avis c'est le
seul moyen de réduire le nombre de
nouveaux cas dans notre pays
face à la flambée de l'épidémie de coved
19 et aux diverses restrictions mises en
place
les malaisiens ont des raisons de
s'inquiéter pour leur économie
la banque mondiale a ainsi révisé ses
prévisions de croissance pour le pays à
quatre et demi pour cent cette année
alors que ses projections initiales
tablaient sur 6 % au brésil à présent
trois sénateurs ont demandé à la cour
suprême l'ouverture d'une enquête contre
le président jean pierre boltz honnart
au c3 politiques de l'opposition
reproche au président brésilien d'avoir
fermé les yeux sur des irrégularités
constatées dans l'achat de vaccins anti
qu'ovide 19 jaillir mode sonar aux
études et côte cette tentative de fraude
et n'aurait pas alerté les autorités
j'ai déposé aujourd'hui une plainte
pénale auprès de la cour suprême en
raison de la grave accusation selon
laquelle le président n'a pris aucune
mesure après avoir été informé d'un
gigantesque système de corruption au
sein du ministère de la santé
les malversations sont des crimes
exposées dans le code pénal et par
conséquent nous comprenons la nécessité
pour la cour suprême et le bureau du
procureur général d'établir une
procédure d' enquête
j'aime le plus meurtri par la pandémie
et des ports plus de cinq cent mille
morts depuis la semaine dernière les
services de santé sont saturés et
jaillir molson arrow est de plus en plus
critiqué pour sa gestion de la crise
quand un mot clair les hôpitaux
brésilien au bord de l'asphyxié
encore convalescent de sa deuxième vague
de qu'ovide 19 le brésil craint
l'émergence d'un regain épidémique sur
son territoire le personnel soignant
déjà à bout de forces est désemparé dans
cet hôpital éphémère de sao paulo
médecins et infirmiers n'hésite pas à
désigner ja airball sonar ou comme
responsable de cette situation
parfois il vaut mieux donner l'exemple
plutôt que de parler
le président de la république ne porte
jamais le masque en public ils
organisent des grands rassemblements en
pleine épidémie
il dit que le coronavirus n'est qu'une
petite grippe
cela ne fait qu'empirer les choses donc
oui le gouvernement doit être reconnu
responsable des cinq cent mille morts au
brésil dans le pays la situation
hospitalière est déjà critique dans 19
de ses 27 états le taux d'occupation des
lits en réanimation s'élève à plus de
80%
un pourcentage qui monte à plus de 90% à
sao paulo
épicentre de l'épidémie dans les rues de
la mégalopole
les brésiliens ne cachent pas leur
inquiétude face à la possibilité d'une
troisième vague de covile 19
nous sommes très inquiet chaque
dirigeant dit une chose différente de
l'autre on ne sait plus qui écouter les
gens ne portent quasiment plus le masque
la campagne de vaccination avance très
lentement
l'arrivée d'une troisième vague inquiète
d'autant plus que le variant delta est
déjà au brésil
je pense que la troisième vague est une
réalité au brésil car la majorité de la
population n'a pas encore été vaccinés
si le gouvernement avait misé sur la
vaccination dès le début nous aurions
peut-être pu éviter la troisième vague
sao paulo et la ville brésilienne
déplorant le plus de morts depuis le
début de la pandémie
de plus le brésil ne peut pas s'appuyer
sur une campagne de vaccination massive
de sa population pour enrayer la
propagation du virus et notamment des
nouveaux variants 6 33% de la population
ont reçu au moins une dose de vaccin
seulement 12% ont complété leur parcours
vaccinale et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis sao paulo avec daniela
be médecins en conseil du consulat de
france et notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir un bon soir daniel
habib merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france vous êtes donc à sao paulo
un épicentre on l'a dit de l'épidémie on
a le sentiment vraiment envie
l'extérieur c'est le cas de le dire de
que l'épidémie chez vous au brésil ne
faiblit jamais qui à cette triste
constante
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas sur le
terrain comment vous qualifier la
situation
je vais vous expliquer un petit peu
d'abord quand les gens parlent de
troisième vague c'est quelque chose de
très confus en fait ce qui s'est passé
au brésil c'est qu'on a eu une première
vague on mai de l'année dernière donc on
a eu une grosse quantité de cas on a eu
au contraire de l'europe et des
etats-unis une descente très lente sur
la quantité de patients le cas dont deux
malades et même de mort et c'est tombé
très doucement on était bien en novembre
ce qui s'est passé après c'est qu'il ya
eu une deuxième vague et moins je
n'appelle pas ça la troisième vague
c'est la deuxième vague qui simplement
continue alors la deuxième vague
elle s'est quand même atténuée quand on
regarde les chiffres du début d'avril où
on a eu le pic de la deuxième vague
les chiffres commencent à tomber on a
déjà dans la ville de sao paulo vacciner
avec deux doses
des vaccins coville on a déjà fait un
million sept cent mille personnes
le but c'est de vacciner dans la ville
de sao paulo 8 millions 400 mille
personnes dont on est encore un peu loin
du résultat qu'on devrait obtenir et en
fait on a une descente ou du cac on a eu
un pic en avril
on est tombé par rapport à avril sur le
nombre d'occasions et alizée on était à
2300 maintenant on est à 1600 mhz et
1600 c'est pratiquement le nombre de cas
qu'on avait quand on a commencé le pic
de l'épidémie en mai de l'année dernière
donc ce que je peux dire c'est que on
est monté en nombre de cas de morts
beaucoup plus on a une deuxième vague
très violente
pire que la première et qui est encore
sur une descente très lente
on vaccine à un rythme qui n'est pas
assez important on a vacciné 20% de la
population cible dans la ville de sao
paulo et 12 millions pour est vacciné 8
millions carte ce qui est 70 % des
adultes au dessus de 18 ans on a vacciné
millions de 700 inscrits dont alain
tarabine pourquoi c'est aussi long en
europe et dans d'autres pays on laxiste
est une sorte de plafond de verre avec
certains qui ont une défiance envers le
vaccin est ce que c'est le cas chez vous
aussi ou tout simplement il manque de
vaccins non non au brésil là ce qui est
c'est là où on juge bolton à roue et
responsable c'est que les vaccins ont
mis très longtemps à arriver
ça c'est le gros problème au brésil là
les brésiliens vont tout ce hack signer
il ya là que chaque fois que je descende
chez moi dans la rue il ya la queue dans
les centres de vaccination les
brésiliens veulent se faire vacciner
le problème c'est que les vaccins
n'arrive pas avec le rythme qui serait
désirable donc c'est ça le gros problème
on commence à observer une légère
descente du nombre de cas mais je pense
qu'au brésil d'une manière optimiste et
pauthe est optimiste novembre mais on en
aura fini l'épidémie malheureusement au
brésil seulement à partir de descendre
cette année ici jusque là il faut
attendre un nombre assez grand de cas et
malheureusement de mots vous avez vu
vous l'avez dit un homme important de
4go vie d'un de décès on a tous vu ces
images dramatiques en provenance du
brésil est ce qu'on ne peut pas aussi
tabler sur une immunité collective du
tout simplement au fait que beaucoup de
personnes au brésil virus ce qui s'est
passé à mal et rose a montré que cette
immunité collective acquise par
l'immunité naturelle elle marche pas du
tout en fait à manas où il y avait déjà
70% de la population qui avait eu
qu'ovide en mars avril de l'année
dernière ils ont été frappés par une
deuxième vague très violente en janvier
nous ici dans le sud un peu plus à sao
paulo ça a été fin mars début avril
mais ce qu'on peut ce qu'on a pu
observer sur la réalité c'est que
l'immunité naturelle ne confère pas
d'immunité durable et on peut pas
s'attendre à cette espèce d'immunité
pour observer une diminution du nombre
des cas il faut vacciner vacciner
vacciner et malheureusement il nous
manque des vaccins on voudrait bien
maxime est beaucoup plus mais
malheureusement les vaccins manque
encore effectivement vous avez cité son
nom tout à l'heure le président bolle
sonar où il ya eu un scandale à son
sujet est ce qu'avec ce scandale la
confiance des brésiliens dans les
autorités pour résoudre cette crise et
est totalement rompu on savait qu'ils
avaient encore quelques partisans mais
là quelle est la situation dans ses
relations avec la population brésilienne
je vous explique un petit peu le
problème avec bolton aoc que pour les on
sait aujourd'hui que les mesures de
sécurité
là la plus grosse mesures de sécurité
qu'on peut faire c'est adopter
l'utilisation des masques et
malheureusement le président lui les
masques ça lui plaît pas alors l'exemple
que le président donne est un mauvais
exemple
ça c'est un gros problème le deuxième
problème c'est que il ya eu beaucoup de
retard par rapport à l'adoption des
vaccins et dont on a commencé à vacciner
en début février moi même j'ai
l'acs signer le 9 ou le 10 février
donc alors que l'europe et les états
unis ont commencé à vacciner en décembre
janvier avec une grosse quantité de
vaccins je sais que la france vous êtes
plus ou moins 25% de vaccination la
population nous au brésil on est à 12 %
le brésil est un pays énorme on et 212
millions d'habitants il faudrait qu'on
ait une quantité beaucoup plus grand de
vaccins si on les avait tous le monde se
ferait vacciner et on aurait une
réduction l'épidémie beaucoup plus
rapide 107 sens cet effet vaccination
c'est ce que je vous dis moi je pense
qu'on aura réglé la situation par
rapport à l'épidémie
seulement en novembre décembre de cette
année ci merci beaucoup en tout cas
daniel habite d'avoir été avec mon vous
avoir exposé en cette situation au
brésil
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de plusieurs eurodéputés
placée sur la liste noire du parlement
européen pour de faux voyage
d'observation électorale puis ce sera
les liteaux des lexsi poulain emmanuel
macron devrait décider très bientôt s'il
doit relancer la réforme controversée
des retraites de pouvoir renouer avec
son image de formateurs mais aussi
peut-être ravivé la colère d'une partie
de la population
d
[Musique]
au carrefour d'une pollution insultes et
d'une nécessité technologique absolue
les terres rares sont au coeur des défis
du 21e siècle c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour tous les prix puisque leur accès
est aujourd'hui principalement chinois
en l'état actuel des capacités minières
connu la part chinoise et réserve
mondiale est de l'ordre de 37 % dans la
cadre de la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis la chine utilise sa position
comme levier de négociations mais il est
clair qu'avec les pénuries et les
tensions que nous allons connaître sur
certaines des rares il faut envisager
d'autres solutions
[Musique]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une des plus importantes
compagnies de taxis en france l'activité
a repris sdap elmander paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour là l'avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
d'aller à cuba 5 6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivé là
concurrents des vtc gros gros choc
d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé les 20000 à
45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligne tout ce qui est au niveau social
surtout au niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en temps
dans tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et non surtout au niveau au niveau
football et ça c'est au champion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues avaient
identifié chez des algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
feront normalement les cellules
sensibles à la lumière dans la rétine
pas ce qu'il va dire qu'il voit un peu
c'est il distingue la lumière il
distingue quoi exactement par le patient
avec la pop a par exemple de reconnaître
les passages protégés dans la rue de
détecter des objets différents objets de
petite taille de grande taille plusieurs
niveaux central de les compter de les
attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui ne
voyait plus rien depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est déjà une source d'espoir
c'est évidemment pas un point définitif
du parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez boxart y allons faire
connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bahia là on
est alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois cholet en profiter
en 2011 et ne demande pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tous les soucis sont toutes les
décroissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne savent pas je ne pensais
jamais de ma vie faire la plonge et
autonomie vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
21h merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici l'équipe de l'actualité de ce
mardi 29 juin placée sur liste noire
c'est le sort réservé par le parlement
européen à cinq eurodéputés français
pour de supposées fonds voyage
d'observation électorale parmi eux
thierry mariani ex candidat en paca qui
dénonce un parlement de plus en plus
totalitaire
ils ne seront donc plus admis pour
participer aux missions d'observation
des élections qu'organise le parlement
emmanuel macron devrait décider avant le
14 juillet s'il doit ou non lancé la
réforme controversée des retraites mis
de côté depuis 16 mois paris évidemment
risqué dix mois de la présidentielle
pour un chef d'état qui souhaite prouver
qu'il est le réformateur qu'il avait
promis d'être le président qui était en
visite aujourd'hui dans les nouveaux
locaux parisiens de la banque américaine
jpmorgan d'horreur contexte plus
favorable aux affaires
états unis irlande et royaume uni
demande une réunion d'urgence du conseil
de sécurité sur le tigre et en ethiopie
hier les troupes du front de libération
du peuple du tigré sont rentrés dans les
capitales régionales mais qu'elle est
mais dans le même temps le pouvoir
central addis abeba a annoncé deviens
cessez le feu unilatéral et
inconditionnel une reprise de la ville
par les troupes du tplf fêté par la
population
des eurodéputés du rassemblement
national sanctionnés ils sont cinq à
avoir été placée sur la liste noire du
parlement européen pour avoir effectué
deux supposés faux voyage d'observation
électorale candidat malheureux aux
régionales en paca thierry mariani fait
partie des personnes concernées et juge
que le parlement européen devient je
cite une institution de plus en plus
totalitaire pourront parler
nous sommes en direct avec virginie
joron euros d'écouté pouvant aussi sur
cette fameuse liste noire bonsoir
virginie joron merci d'être avec nous
alors pour bien comprendre qu est ce qu
on vous reproche exactement pour que
votre nom atterrissent avec d'autres sur
une liste noire c'est une forme de
sanction politique selon vous j'aimerais
bien savoir ce qu'on me reproche
effectivement il ya un an effectivement
nous sommes déplacés en russie en crimée
moi j'ai appris que j'étais sur une
fiche
enfin j'étais fiche est plutôt que
d'être sanctionné lundi donc j'ai pas
été auditionnés j'ai pas été alerté du
fait que je sois allé l'année dernière
en crimée pour effectivement observé au
titre de mon mandat de député
parlementaire d'une élection qui se
déroulait dans l'état de en russie et en
prime et donc voilà donc je découvre
cette liste noire avec vous depuis lundi
je vois qu'il ya pas mal de
désinformation autour de ce fait qui est
un fait avéré est aussi transparent
puisque moi j'ai aimé le collègue
nous avons déclaré de cette mission
auprès du parlement et la voilà
peut-être le timing est presque parce
que bon mais un peu trop tard parce que
les élections sont passées on nous sort
ce dossier pour faire du bruit pour nous
salir et nous ne sommes pas dû c'est une
sanction entre guillemets politique
parce que moi je considère que mon
mandat de parlementaire me permet
d'aller là où j'ai envie d'aller
je vous rappelle que les traités nous
permettent d'aller où on veut
la libre circulation en soi et voilà je
pense que c'est une communication de la
part d'un groupuscule qui oscille pas
permettez-moi de lit
jusqu'à aujourd'hui après deux ans de
mandat je n'avais pas connaissance de
cette délégation
peut-être qu'ils sont jaloux du fait que
nous souhaitons sommes allés là bas voir
ce qu'il s'est passé si eux ne
souhaitent pas y aller
eh bien nous moi je considère qu'une
élection et peut aussi être vu par
d'autres députés et à ce jour
effectivement je m'interroge sur le
fondement de cette soi-disante liste
noire et sanctions voilà il faut se
poser des questions pourquoi ça tombe
maintenant pour qui c'est ce sont ces
sanctions
et c'est quoi le but parce que d'autres
députés et aussi par de telles missions
on l'a bien vu au venezuela une députée
de la france insoumise ou encore un
autre membre du ku partir au kazakhstan
a eu par contre on peut être senti ont
donc encore une fois voilà on veut
mettre le zoom sur sur new bond je
trouve que c'est assez injuste
ça tombe un peu peut-être presque pour
eux mal parce que les élections sont
passées mais sur le fond voilà c'est
plutôt une question politique
on voit bien le parlement dès qu'ils
peuvent être anti russe entre guillemets
ou sanctionner des personnalités qui ont
l'outrecuidance d'aller en russie ou en
crimée bon ben voilà on a ce type de
communication et encore une fois je suis
sur arize
c'est plus selon vous la destination on
pose problème
plus peut-être que votre parti on est on
est dans une forme d'idéologie selon
vous en tout cas vu les arguments a
énoncé qui tiennent pas la route je vous
dis ça fait un an que nous sommes partis
d'un pas on n'a pas été auditionné
on sait pas sur quelle base ils se sont
fondés effectivement voilà les élections
peut-être permis de ressortir ce dossier
du fond du tiroir
et puis on sait pardonner mois le faut
je suis en voyage d'observation
électorale est ce que vous avez pu
prouver votre bonne foi qu'ils n'étaient
pas fausses et ses voyages c'est quoi un
faux voyage pardonnez moi il ya des
élections en russie c'est une vraie
élection non je sais pas à la base c'est
pour moi une direction a gelé vu tout le
monde l'a vu même vous les journalistes
ont reporté qu'il ya une consultation
populaire
donc voilà un mois ce titre j'y vais je
vois que je vois sur place qui a une
organisation d'élections les images
démontrent aussi
voilà ce je vois pas aujourd'hui
pourquoi on nous reproche le fait d'y
être allé si ce n'est que c'est parce
que ça en russie et en crimée et
pardonnez moi encore une fois la crimée
si on veut lui couper l'oxygène mais il
faut le dire mais le peuple le peuple là
bas
existe il ya des instances haussier
représentatif de l'état ça c'est un fait
et d'y aller pour moi n'est pas un crime
contre l'humanité ce que j'ai déjà dit
mais je pense que c'est vraiment c'est
plutôt politique c'est c'est le fait
qu'on soit aussi du rassemblement
national
voilà on s'est dit allez on va un peu
faire du bruit on va encore dire qu'ils
font n'importe quoi
ce qui est totalement faux ça fait un an
que nous sommes allés nous avons été
totalement transparent la déclaration
sont faites on parle de voyage luxueux
mais ce qui est complètement faux
puisque vous voyez bien dans nos
déclarations qu'il n'y a rien de
dispendieux ou de fous donc là encore
une fois c'est de la désinformation
orchestrée organisé par certains ont pu
skull du parlement est encore
aujourd'hui vient de recevoir ce jour
une demande
cette fameuse délégation qui organise
des élections pour une formation mois de
septembre d'un côté on nous black list
et de l'autre on nous invite à des
formations un moment donné faut être
cohérent soit en double à kyste et en
élimine du processus
ou alors on fait bien les choses et on
nous invite
assez assez comment dire ces
observations officielle du parlement
européen
thierry mariani dénonce les hausses
élyséen dénonça parlement de plus en
plus totalitaire c'est votre avis aussi
bien oui bah vous le voyez ça veut dire
quoi c'est qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
les nauru notre mandat pourrait vous
amener c'est à dire qu'au jour
moi je demande dans cette liste de pays
où j'ai le droit d'aller 1 est-ce qu'il
faut s'appeler bhl pour aller là où on a
envie d'aller
moi je regrette que le parlement
effectivement applique des règles qui en
fait dénonce c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
celle inverse c'est à dire quand on nous
imposant des restrictions
alors qu'en même temps on dénonce ces
restrictions dans des états qui se dit
qu'ils qui veulent montrer qu'ils sont
des démocraties donc à un moment donné
il faut être cohérent
après voilà s'il ya des siennes liste de
pays où on ne peut pas aller faut nous
le dire faut être précis et en même
temps voilà moi c'est parce je le
regrette parce que notre mandat nous
permet d'aller là où tout le monde
pourrait aller mais qui met par
idéologie ne veulent pas y aller moi
j'invite les journalistes
j'invite tous les autres députés à y
aller à ces élections et par eux-mêmes
voir ce qu'il s'y passe ils se feront
aussi leur propre opinion
merci vers gênés genre en euros dp tél
rennes d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france l'union européenne ne
lutte pas suffisamment contre le
blanchiment d'argent et le financement
du terrorisme dans le secteur bancaire
c'est la conclusion d'un rapport de la
cour des comptes européenne publiée ce
lundi à cause d'un cadre de survie rond
sujet peu solide et incohérent le manque
à gagner s'élèverait à plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros chaque
année pour l'europe a les explications
en images
[Musique]
les faiblesses au niveau de l'union
européenne en matière de blanchiment de
capitaux et de financement du terrorisme
doivent être corrigés et le rôle de
surveillance de l'union européenne doit
être considérablement renforcé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la politique toujours en france emmanuel
macron doit décider avant le 14 juillet
s'il doit relancer la réforme
controversée des retraites mise de côté
depuis 16 mois un pari risqué à dix mois
de la présidentielle pour un président
qui soit de prouver qu'il est le
réformateur qu'il avait promis d'être le
chef de l'état qui était en visite
aujourd'hui dans les nouveaux locaux de
la banque américaine jp morgan à paris
marquant ainsi notamment le retour des
activités financières en france grâce
aux briques site pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexis me poulin c'est notre
rubrique lenny tôt ce soir bonsoir
alexis poulain alors est-ce que emmanuel
macron on va pousser coûte que coûte la
dernière grande réforme de son
quinquennat la réforme des retraites qui
pourrait mettre le feu aux poudres dans
le contexte sanitaire con qu'on connaît
tous bien on al impression qu
effectivement c'est le dernier coup de
force 1 le sprinter l'avant de la ligne
d'arrivée 2022 il faut faire passer
cette réforme sans quoi son bilan de
réformateurs sera à peu près 0 et
vis-à-vis des électeurs de droite qu'ils
essayent de drague gay depuis des mois
ça ferait quand même un léger trouble un
léger malaise donc il y a eu 1 1 déjà
une campagne autour de cette réforme des
retraites qui est indispensable dont on
n'aurait pas le choix de faire
l'économie qui doit arriver et qui va
forcément arriver la question c'est
quand et bruno le maire en parlait les
différents porteurs de la république en
marche en parlait également et le
président qui laisse planer le doute en
disant que oui il devra prendre des
décisions difficiles peut-être durant
l'été qui pourrait peut-être
compromettre sa candidature donc ça
pourrait être cette réforme des
retraites qui rappelez-vous avait mis à
tous les partenaires sociaux dans la rue
demandant davantage de débats davantage
de clarifications
il y avait eu de nombreux couacs 1 le
monsieur retraites jean paul delvaux
avait été obligé de démissionner suite à
ses nombreux mandats qu'ils n'avaient
pas déclaré et tout ça avait continué
ensuite avec le candidat malheureux de
la république en marche dans les hauts
de france également qui avait pris le
dossier retraite donc ce dossier
retraites à l'arrêt on a l'impression
qu'elle manquerait on veut absolument le
remettre sur la table et le pousser
jusqu'au bout
en bien décalant l'âge de la retraite
jusqu'à 64 ans de même si ce n'était pas
dans son programme
au contraire sa promesse de programmes
c'était de ne pas décaler l'âge du
départ à la retraite dans les cinq ans
qui viennent
or il parle maintenant de réforme
paramétrique et on sent bien qu'il est
gêné parce que cette réforme elle est
demandée par bruxelles dans les
conditions du plan de relance de
l'argent européen ces 40 milliards
donnés par bruxelles enfin prêter
puisqu'il s'agit de dettes et d'emprunts
et bien il faut que la france accepte de
faire des réformes systémiques retraites
mais aussi bien sur l'assurance-chômage
assurance chômage qui elle aussi a eu un
coup d'arrêt suite à l'avis du conseil
d'état qui a expliqué que ce n'était pas
forcément le moment compte tenu
aujourd'hui de l'état du marché de
l'emploi
pas forcément très bonne santé même si
les prédictions de bruno le maire reste
tout à fait optimiste à 5% contre
parfois la vie de la banque de france
qui s'inquiète de l'apparition du delta
du variant delta bien sûr et de
l'incertitude qui plane encore sur la
reprise économique mais voilà où on en
est aujourd'hui
visiblement coûte que coûte emmanuel
macron veut réformer les retraites avant
son départ rien président alexis tout
occupé à la relance quitte à en oublier
les autres priorités
oui c'est assez incroyable de voir
l'agenda du président de la république
il était la semaine dernière à
l'ouverture de la samaritaine ouvert par
bernard arnault en fendant vantant les
nombreux emplois qui étaient là et le
luxe à la française qui allait
accueillir de nombreux touristes
quand la crise sanitaire sera derrière
nous il était hier à douai pour
l'inauguration d'une usine
sino-japonaises de batteries électriques
avec xavier bertrand le président
vainqueur des régionales de la région de
france avec une passe d'armes entre les
deux hommes tout à fait lunaire où
xavier bertrand lui parle de
l'abstention de la difficulté de
raccrocher les wagons avec le peuple
français emmanuel macron qui lui parle
de la relance et de l'importance
finalement de travail est de faire de
l'emploi
et puis ensuite il se met en scène comme
d'habitude avec un micro au milieu des
ouvriers pour expliquer que c'est
formidable investissement dans notre
pays et le soir même il était à
versailles pour dîner avec des grands
patrons du monde entier c'était une
semaine tous france des patron
d'arcelormittal mais aussi de la banque
d'affaires jpmorgan et
bien d'autres qui étaient autour du
président cette fois ci pour promettre
7000 emplois selon bruno le maire c'est
bien peu quand on sait les milliards que
brasse ces multinationales qui sont à
peu près partout dans le même temps
arcelormittal si elle choisit la france
eh bien elle quitte l'italie où elle est
en train là de liquides et de nombreuses
usines et donc on voit bien qu'il ya
comme ça une volonté d'être celui qui va
lancer la relance d'une certaine façon
comme il peut le faire comme il essaye
de le faire systématiquement parce que
maintenant son bilan sera aussi celui là
est ce que les 5 % promis par bercy sont
possibles
c'est pas forcément ce que pense la
banque de france aujourd'hui et puis est
ce la place d'un président français
d'être à l'ouverture des locaux d'une
banque d'affaires américaine jp morgan à
paris je trouve ça légèrement déplacé de
voir le président se déplacer lui-même
personnellement pour féliciter ces deux
financiers internationaux qui viennent
simplement la sphère des affaires parce
que le break site est passée par là il
ya là un message tout à fait biaisé et
on voit bien la difficulté qu'a emmanuel
macron à incarner la fonction de chef
d'état il est là dans son rôle plutôt de
vendeur international comme il l'avait
fait en héros de la start up nation et
il fait ça pour quoi pour attirer des
investisseurs étrangers et dire que
finalement la france redémarre et pour
ce faire et bien il réforme le marché de
l'emploi il réforme des retraites et il
continue finalement le brader les bijoux
de famille un c'était le cas avec alstom
et puis aussi la république sociale qui
visiblement en huile et les
investisseurs aient beaucoup
d'incertitudes et lexie poulain le delta
vous réparez la croissance et une
stratégie et politique tout de même
difficile à lire il faut jouer les
équilibristes complètement on
on voit que la stratégie aujourd'hui des
mails macron c'est celle de l'autruche
il fait comme si les élections
régionales n'avait pas eu lieu
il fait comme si le variant delta
n'existait pas ou n'existera pas cet été
on verra plus tard à la rentrée comment
ça se passera et il est uniquement
concentré sur son art hâtif sur le tempo
qu'il veut se donner personnellement
pour relancer sa campagne
c'est le discours du 14 juillet
extrêmement attendu avec beaucoup de
communication autour de ce discours
comme celui de la refondation
on attend de voir ce qu'il va vraiment
dire il est aussi question de réunir le
parlement en congrès
versailles pour faire des annonces alors
serait ce les fameuses annonces sur les
retraites et d'autres choses
on attend et on a l'impression comme ça
que il essaye d entretenir un suspense
permanent parce qu'il n'a rien à dire ou
parce qu'il veut le dire au bon moment
quand les français seront en vacances
quand il va oublier quand ils ne
pourront pas descendre dans la rue ou ne
voudront pas ou quand il va falloir
peut-être prendre des mesures de
restrictions sanitaires à cause bien sûr
de la multiplication du verlan delta sur
le territoire donc c'est illisible
évidemment c'est beaucoup d'incertitudes
y compris pour les milieux économiques
qui se demande finalement si emmanuel
macron incapable de tenir quelques unes
de ses promesses puisque les réformes
n'arrive pas être sont trop lentes à
venir et si jamais il fallait il voulait
les faire trop rapidement ça pourrait
braqué bien sûr l'opinion publique et
amener davantage de blocage comme on
l'avait vu lors de du 49 3 et de la
première mouture de cette réforme des
retraites donc clairement aujourd'hui sa
stratégie c'est celle de gagner du temps
de continuer à se mettre en scène avec
ses pérégrinations au sein du pays
auprès des usines des ouvriers puis des
populations et d'essayer de reconnecter
avec la population française il est aidé
en cela par des instituts de sondages
complaisants qui continuent à donner des
sondages où il est toujours en train de
monter alors que réellement je crois que
il ya quand même beaucoup d'incertitudes
autour de la cote de popularité des
mails macron et de ses capacités et à
réformer et à donner une ligne claire
pour la suite des opérations
alors justement dans ce contexte comment
peut-il s'assurer une chance de
réélection en 2022 si les candidats mais
la première des choses que doit faire
emmanuel macron s'il veut se donner une
chance et s'il se représente c'est de
clarifier les choses
aujourd'hui tout est flou et quand c'est
flou et bien ça comme on dit c'est qu'il
ya un loup et on le sait bien s'il veut
passer la réforme des retraites il doit
être clair il doit pour cela engager une
nouvelle grande concertation en disant
que cela n'arrivera qu'après l'élection
de 2022 il ne peut pas vouloir la faire
passer de force avant donc peut-être que
là il sera mal un dedans en juin le
temps avec les partenaires sociaux
et puis l'autre choses extrêmement
importantes s'il veut aussi pouvoir se
présenter face aux français il doit
clarifier leurs même temps le en même
temps atteint sa limite extrême quand on
a vu la passe d'armes entre le ministre
de l'intérieur et le ministre de la
justice qui ne viennent pas du même bord
politique
on comprend bien que ce gouvernement de
jean castex ne tient qu'à un fil
il ya trop de sensibilités politiques
différentes
les régionales sont passées par là
beaucoup de ministres et bien ont perdu
et les ego aussi ont pris beaucoup dans
cette bataille et ce qu'ils pouvaient
tenir avec beaucoup de communication
beaucoup d'enrobage ne tient plus parce
que l'idéologie prime est aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron clairement essaye de
draguer les électeurs de droite de
devenir un candidat de droite
sa stratégie après avoir diminué le
parti socialiste était celle de diminuer
les républicains or les résultats des
régionales revigore ces deux anciens
partis parce qu'ils ont sauvé les
régions qu'ils avaient est presque aussi
il montre que existe au local aux
régionales eaux territoriales aux
municipales et que ce seront des parties
ancré dans les territoires qui
connaissent le pays là où la république
en marche n'est qu'un parti parisiens
finalement loin des réalités et emmanuel
macron aux dires de certains de ses
conseillers qui se bunkérise encore
davantage à l'elysée et qui ne voit plus
du tout finalement quels sont les
ficelles pour tirer et r reconnecter
avec le pays réel donc la qualification
sera difficile pour lui parce que ça
veut dire qu'il abandonnera une grande
partie de son jeu politique qui était
d'être est de ne pas être d'être le en
même temps permanent et de dire tout et
son contraire
maintenant il va devoir dire des choses
et surtout les assumer merci alexis pour
l'un d'avoir été avec nous pour votre
édito les députés ont adopté
définitivement la loi de bioéthique qui
prévoit entre autres l'élargissement de
la procréation médicalement assistée aux
couples lesbiens et aux femmes seules
les précisions de katia pique nique
le parlement a bien adopté
définitivement le projet de loi de
bioéthique après deux ans de navettes
parlementaires et bien sûr sa mesure
phare et l'ouverture de la procréation
médicalement assistée aux couples de
femmes et aux femmes célibataires
le sénat avait refusé la troisième
lecture du texte mais ici à l'assemblée
il a été adopté à une large majorité 326
députés
nouveauté pour 115 ou voté contre il ya
également 42 abstentions
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
a expliqué que les textes d'application
ont été préparées afin que des premiers
enfants puissent être conçues avant la
fin de l'année 2021 il a salué un jour
historique mais
les opposants à cette mesure n'ont pas
dit leur dernier mot quelques députés
aient l'air et eu d y ont déposé un
recours auprès du conseil
constitutionnel
mais il y avait également des opposants
à cette mesure dans la société comme la
manif pour tous qui a dénoncé un passage
en force
si une association lgbt a évoqué un
accouchement dans la douleur c'est parce
que les militants lgbt défendre ce
projet depuis de nombreuses années
françois hollande lab est évoquée mais
ne l'avait pas concrétisé en revanche
c'était une promesse d' emmanuel macron
la pma pour toutes les femmes étant déjà
autorisés en espagne en suède où
portugal donc en grande bretagne cette
mesure fera donc le bonheur des couples
de femmes et de femmes célibataires qui
devait se rendre à l'étranger pour
pouvoir concevoir un enfant
jusqu'ici 2400 femmes par an environ
devait effectuer ce voyage est la loi
bien été définitivement votée par
l'assemblée nationale donc la pma qui ne
sera plus réservé uniquement aux couples
hétérosexuels une mesure qui a suscité
de nombreuses polémiques et a
profondément divisé la classe politique
retour sur les grandes étapes de cette
loi avec françois xavier lambert c'est
le projet phare de la loi bioéthique
l'extension de la procréation
médicalement assistée aux couples de
femmes et aux femmes célibataires
la mesure était réclamée depuis des
années par certaines associations sur le
modèle de ce qui existe déjà dans
plusieurs pays européens comme l'espagne
la suède ou le portugal ce projet de loi
entamé son parcours parlementaire à
l'automne 2010 neuf dans un premier
temps le sénat dominé par la droite
l'avait voté avec sa mesure
d'élargissement de la pma excluant
toutefois la prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale mais en deuxième
lecture les sénateurs ont adopté dans la
confusion le texte amputé de cette
mesure emblématique
finalement l'assemblée nationale a donc
eu le dernier mot
après 500 heures de débat au parlement
au fil des mois des dizaines de milliers
de personnes se sont mobilisées contre
le texte
la manif pour tous et plusieurs
associations catholiques ont dénoncé un
passage en force avec le refus
systématique selon elle de modifier le
projet initial selon ces associations et
la manif pour tous la pma pour toutes
les femmes va inéluctablement conduire à
la gestation pour autrui
au nom de l'égalité en faveur des hommes
la loi bioéthique permettent également
de reconnaître sous condition la
filiation des enfants nés de gpa à
l'étranger
cependant la gestation pour autrui
demeure en france une ligne rouge
infranchissable selon les mots du
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti
cette loi de bioéthique peut néanmoins
s'appuyer sur le soutien d'une majorité
de l'opinion publique
67% des français ils sont désormais
favorables selon un récent sondage ifop
pour l'association des familles
homoparentales
désormais la réforme devrait être
rapidement mise en place
les textes d'application ont été
préparées afin que les premiers enfants
puissent être conçues avant la fin de
l'année 2021 selon le ministre de la
santé olivier ferrand toutefois en
recours auprès du conseil
constitutionnel de députés l air et udi
pourrait retarder de quelques semaines
la promulgation de la loi
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons la rencontre entre le
président du gouvernement espagnol pedro
sanchez et le président catalan psr à
gonesse
reprise du dialogue avec madrid qui est
prévue fin septembre
et puis nous reviendrons sur la
situation dans la région du tigré en
ethiopie l'italie les états unis
l'irlande et le royaume-uni pardon
demande une réunion d'urgence au conseil
de sécurité
[Musique]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une importante compagnie de
taxis en france l'activité a repris sda
actuellement dans paris ou par les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de tourisme
étranger les chauffeurs sont un peu à la
peine garé ya bien cinq six ans vous
aviez un monopole est sûre ce est
arrivée la concurrente bb&t gros gros
choc d'offre on est passé de on a on a
doublé les 20000 à 45 mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur les
mobilités réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui ait des candidats
n'y a pas d'alternative en sort du
politique
il est clair pour tout le monde attend
saft est ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre qu'il est
probable qu'il faille prendre un certain
nombre de mesures un peu autoritaire
c'est intéressant on comprend que vous
soyez des sous les libéraux l'uniforme
c'est quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
dignité gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était les gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
je
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis que le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers étaient compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rexy le vrai
sujet c'est celui de faire dialoguer les
douaniers français les poignées
britannique est ce qui m'inquiète dans
le bric site c'est pas le plexi c'est la
bureaucratie du brics comment ça va se
passer par exemple pour l'été qui arrive
la côte d'azur verra peu ou pas
d'anglais je suspecte effectivement le
gouvernement britannique d'essayer de
convaincre les britanniques de rester en
grande bretagne pour faciliter la
relance de l'économie britannique par
rapport à la crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez en
espagne le premier ministre socialiste
pedro sanchez a reçu à madrid le
président de la catalogne
l'indépendantiste perret aragonès pour
plus de précisions nous retrouvons tout
de suite leslie est cinglant en direct
de barcelone
bonsoir les ch'tis c'est donc la
première fois que le chef du
gouvernement espagnol reçoit le
président catalan depuis les élections
catalanes y qui date de février dernier
c'est donc une nouvelle étape dans dans
le dialogue entre la france entre l'as
pardon à la catalogne et madrid
eh bien oui car pedro sanchez souhaité
que cette réunion soit un point de
rencontre pour construire une nouvelle
relation qui permettant de trouver des
solutions pour la cohabitation
alors c'est dans le palais de la moncloa
à madrid que s'est déroulée la réunion
aujourd'hui
elle a duré pas moins de 2 heures 40 le
président pereira gomes le président
catalan a tenu ensuite une conférence de
presse pour expliquer ce qui a été dit
est donc le conflit serait résolu sera
résolu avec dialogue et négociation
selon lui qu' l'aministie serait la
solution globale pour résoudre ce
conflit et il a déclaré je cite ne
voulons pas une photo nous voulons
l'aborder en profondeur la négociation
et le dialogue seront les plus complexes
et les plus difficiles que le
gouvernement espagnol devra aborder dans
son histoire contemporaine
alors il a également glissé que les
indépendantistes ont l'ambition de
réussir à obtenir un référendum sur
l'indépendance de la catalogne et
concernant la suite des événements le
dialogue sera repris la troisième
semaine de septembre ça a été actée les
équipes travailleront dans les
prochaines semaines afin de préparer ce
nouveau rendez vous qui devrait se tenir
à barcelone alors ça montre une volonté
de dialogue des deux côtés et les fne
est ce que c'est une relation qui va
durer à long terme entre la catalogne et
madrid
d'un côté on à pedro sanchez qui essaie
de détendre les relations depuis deux
ans il faut rappeler que la rencontre du
jour fait suite à la grâce des neuf
leaders indépendantistes catalans de la
semaine dernière alors pedro sanchez
s'était même déplacé à barcelone
pour annoncer officiellement la nouvelle
alors ces derniers ont été libérés après
trois ans d'incarcération
ils ont été condamnés entre 9 et 13 ans
de prison alors pour le premier ministre
cette libération était indispensable
pour le vivre ensemble pour la
démocratie espagnole car ces neuf
personnes représentent des milliers de
catalans selon ses propres mots mais
malgré tout cela reste très fragile car
aujourd'hui la cour des comptes a livré
une sévère sentence les leaders du
processus indépendantistes et une
quarantaine de hauts fonctionnaires
catalans ont et wav payer plus de 5
millions d'euros au total pour avoir
fait la promotion à l'étranger
duprat tentative de sécession de la
catalogne en 2017
alors parmi eux figurent carlès plus
damon ou encore son ancien
vice-président qui est tout juste sorti
de prison la semaine dernière et donc la
cour des comptes considère que c'est
illégal et que les sommes utilisées pour
avoir fait cette promotion à l'étranger
doivent donc être remboursés alors
perret aragonès a déclaré ce soir qu'il
faudrait trouver une solution ça a donc
retendu la relation entre madrid et la
catalogne
pedro sanchez s'est d'ailleurs exprimée
en indiquant qu' en aucun cas il n'avait
donné d'indication à la cour des comptes
et qu'il n'a qu il a un grand respect
pour leur travail il a fait remarquer
que les personnes concernées pourrait
faire appel merci les strings la
correspondante à barcelone et pour en
parler nous sommes avec jordi vera
coordinateur du mouvement oui au pays
catalan bonsoir jordi vera merci d'être
avec nous alors quelques jours après la
grâce un des neuf dirigeants
indépendantistes cette rencontre tout
d'abord votre
réactions les écouter et marie tu étais
obligé aujourd'hui de se lâcher du lest
parce que c'est
ils ont suivi quand on fait de conseil
de l'europe il ya quelques jours ils ont
vu ils ont pris les devants nourrissant
des prisonniers politiques
mais la situation reste bloquée puisque
ya aucune avancée dans le temps joue en
même temps que ces personnes ont été
libérées comme ça a été dit des 10 et
les autres sont aujourd'hui mises en
examen plus de 3000 personnes sont jour
j aujourd'hui le suivi en catalogne il
ne va pas du tout dans près de denges it
is arrêté l'action contre contre les
indépendants 10 14 vous souhaitez
diffuser et très difficiles négociations
dans ces conditions pourtant le
président catalan affirme ce soir que la
reprise du dialogue avec madrid
eh bien c'était pour fin septembre
c'est la voie de la réconciliation tout
de même se sont donnés deux ans la
majorité au parlement 80 s'est donné
deux ans pour avoir des avancées dans la
négociation avec marc litt
mais il faut il aussi que ces deux
années et donc vont être une période
dans laquelle madrid doit évoluer parce
que si le centre est toujours dans les
mêmes oppositions il est impossible
d'arriver à un accord comme ça a été dit
je vais le répéter il ya deux questions
qui sont fondamentales et je vis dans
notre pertinence d'avoir un référendum
et ensuite une amnistie générale pour
qu'elles aient toutes les personnes qui
ont été poursuivis pendant toutes ces
années qui sont nombreuses aujourd'hui
et c'est là que ça commence
la question fondamentale aussi une des
questions qui sont soumises est question
de l'indépendance au loin de lundi
contre madrid pour l'instant été ravi en
fonction de la pression qui reçoit des
russes tition européenne donc quelque
chose
d'autres tombés et donc ravir tout cas
l'évolution de ma vie mais qui est une
évolution forcément quelque chose
la pression aujourd'hui de toutes les
institutions judiciaires européennes
quand vous dites madrid doit évoluer sur
ses positions pour ouvrir la voie donc à
cette vraie reprise du dialogue et à
cette réconciliation vous pensez à quoi
précisément
écoutez ma le premier ministre espagnol
indique avait une ligne rouge
cet ovaire ligne rouge c'était le
logement à l'autodétermination cet
originaire où je ne permets pas si on
continue à exister ne permet pas
justement de deux franchises pas de
devoirs en tout cas les deux
propositions et nos propositions que
madrid tour pour les faits le catalan
est la proportion des indépendantistes
de ces deux questions
c'est la question qui devrait être
soumise à un référendum dont je ne dis
pas qu'on n'y arrivera pas aujourd'hui
les points les jeunes et de l'autre sont
très éloignées et qu' il faudra en tout
cas que mali évolué puisque les canards
accepte parfaitement de de soumettre la
question de de plus d'autonomie
alors les indépendantistes en tout cas
qu'on passe sur leur position est aussi
monde les mystiques pour toutes les
personnes condamnées pour les événements
de 2017 mais vous l'avez dire aussi
l'organisation d'un référendum
d'autodétermination clairement vous êtes
prêt aussi à lâcher du lest du côté des
indépendantistes
je vous promets que citoyen français
suite aux évènements de nouvelles
clauses calédonie à quelques années il
ya eu il ya eu avant tout une amnistie
et il y en a eu deux donc sur ce point
de secours sur un pays démocratique
homologué en europe devrait parfaitement
accepté les principes démocratiques qui
sont le principe de l'autodétermination
des peuples et des équipes projets par
an pendant majorité parlementaire que
maintenant les élections direction des
indépendantistes
sélection donc c'est quelque chose
équipe dans la durée et ensuite peut pas
négocier avec des dés milliers de
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui dans une
situation inacceptable puisque
aujourd'hui nous avons plus de demandes
qui voit pour certaines c'est savoir
plus de 3 millions d'euros
donc c'est quand même une bonne normal
si on veut négocier il faudra désactiver
toutes ces questions judiciaires qui qui
empêche toute la discussion ait des gens
de la pensée vous qu'un jour clairement
la catalogne obtiendra son sont la
dépendance vous y croyez mais c'est
inévitable
écoutez et une majorité des catalans ont
déconnecté déjà de écologiquement de
l'espagne ils se sentent plus du tout
lié à l'état espagnol
nos voix je prie chaque fois qu'il
quitte la catalogne il ils ont la
visiter en tout les des policiers et les
devants des manifestations des images de
ceux ci et donc c'est une situation qui
ne peut pas durer puisque on peut pas
imposer éternellement un peu plus
nomination que ce n'est pas dix projets
acceptés et surtout à 2021 96 ans et
dans les années précédentes les coups
d'état et des assassinats des exécutions
aujourd'hui c'est plus possible aux
autres forcément un moment donné comme
tout pays démocratique
c'est vrai l'esprit doublement seront
obligés d'accepter en tout cas de
soumettre à un référendum
l'approvisionner dépendance puisque
c'est une réclamation de la majorité des
catalans merci et jordi vera
coordinateur du mouvement oui au pays
catalan d'avoir été avec nous
et direction présent l'afrique avec un
cessez le feu très partiel en ethiopie
dans la région du tigré décrété
unilatéralement par le gouvernement
central après la reprise de la capitale
régionale mekele par les forces rebelles
ces dernières comptent je cite
intensifier leur lutte
grégoire dos et un cessez le feu
unilatéral après l'avancée des forces de
défense tigréenne et la reprise de la
capitale régionale mekele le
gouvernement éthiopien s'est retrouvé
dos au mur conséquence ce cessez le feu
décidé par une seule partie qui pourrait
donc s'avérer très fragile au nom du
tigré et de toutes les personnes éprises
de paix nous demandons au gouvernement
fédéral un cessez le feu basé sur
l'humanité de manière à empêcher de
nouveaux dommages afin qu'il soit
possible pour les gens de trouvait du
répit dans le camp d'en face
l'heure ne semble pas la cessation des
combats après cette avancée
significative
le gouvernement et l'armée du tigré
accompliront toutes les tâches
nécessaires pour assurer la survie et la
sécurité de notre peuple
le gouvernement du tigre et appelle
notre peuple et notre armée du tigre et
intensifier leur lutte jusqu'à ce que
nos ennemis qui complètement le tigre et
de leur côté les nations unies
s'inquiètent de l'aggravation d'une
situation humanitaire déjà terribles
conséquences de ce conflit armé
cette situation rend encore plus
difficile le travail de notre personnel
et l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire
nous appelons au calme et à la retenue
et nous demandons à toutes les parties
au conflit de respecter le droit
international afin de protéger les
civils y compris les personnes déplacées
et de veiller à ce que les travailleurs
humanitaires puissent continuer à
exercer leurs fonctions et à atteindre
autant de personnes que possible qui ont
besoin d'une assistance vitale en ce
moment à l'onu plusieurs délégations
dont les etats-unis la france et
l'irlande appelle désormais à une
réunion d'urgence du conseil de sécurité
sur la question tigréenne et pour en
parler nous sommes avec patrick ferrasse
président de stratégie africaine docteur
en géopolitique spéciale
de la corne de l'afrique un bon soir
patrick ferrasse merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france la reprise donc
de la capitale provinciale du tigré est
ce que pour vous c'est un tournant dans
le conflit en quelque sorte un échec
également pour l'armée fédérale
éthiopienne si les informations que l'on
a entendu depuis hier se confirme ce qu'
a priori le cas puisque les tigres et un
communiqué normands en ce moment ce
qu'ils veulent ce qu'il ne faisait pas
avant ce qu'il dira qu'ils ont la
sibérienne en revanche changé oui ce
sera un tournant sans un tournant parce
que les tigres ont repris mais québec et
leur capital en moins de sept mois tout
en luttant en même temps contre l'armée
éthiopienne la mairie triel elling
samara
donc ça veut dire que l'offensive et
l'arrivée des troupes tigréenne à
michele est une démonstration de la
d'incompétence militaire et de la
suprématie militaire des tigres et un
sur l'armée au caire sera des
conséquences sur le futur de cette armée
qui obtiennent si l'on peut dire donc
que ce qu'on peut dire c'est que oui les
tigres et un remporté de grandes
victoires qui va être un grand tournant
il faut maintenant que le développement
politique suive des forces de défense
geng soutien de la population
à mon avis c'est une des régions où ce
soutien est pratiquement quasi unanime
et au vu de ce qui a été fait comme
exactions pillages viols et tueries de
civils sous les la totalité de la
population est derrière le tipi élèves
le front de libération qui ride donc là
il ya pratiquement aucun souci à ce
faire ils ont pratiquement les 100 94 à
100 % de la population derrière eux
ne pas oublier que beaucoup de jeunes
sont partis dans le maquis pour se
battre et multiplier la fin et femmes
alors les états unis un l'irlande et le
royaume uni ont demandé une réunion
d'urgence du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu a pour bien comprendre qu est-ce
qui va être messieurs sur la table lors
de cette réunion
vous devez pas grande chose pour les
boudègues raison que la dernière la
dernière réunion du conseil de sécurité
s'est finie sur into surcote de
résolution puisque les chinois et les
russes
lang ok il ya de fortes chances que si
cette résolution mais mettez en doute la
souveraineté nationale de l'ethiopie
elle sera bloquée en cuir il faut pas
s'attendre à une résolution je crois que
c'est vendredi qui aura lieu une réunion
faut pas s'attendre à une grande
résolution sur ce côté là depuis le
début le conseiller cotisations unis n'a
pas réussi à fournir 30 chose comme
résolution et en plus avec les chinois
que les russes même les leaders
africains sur les trois pays africains
qui sont membres non permanents du
conseil de sécurité
donc ne nous attendront pas grand chose
de la part de constituer traité des
nations unies justement aucune marge de
manoeuvre vous dit en substance
pourquoi cette réunion c'est une réunion
pour la forme pour faire passer quelques
messages
c'est pour tenter de faire passer un
message sur l'obligation de traiter ce
cas du tigre qui tarde le cas où il y
ait de la famille est une écurie des
exactions commises mais ça fait bien six
mois sept mois celui de ce conseil de
sécurité n'a absolument rien produit les
seuls qui dans la sphère au récit et de
mettre un petit peu le couteau sous la
gorge au gouvernement que pièce les
américains le reste c'est silence
complet sur la sur la planète si l'on
peut dire que ce soit l'union européenne
où l'union africaine vous n'avez
absolument rien vu de la part de ces
trois organisations multilatérales que
ce soit via sont unies l'union
européenne l'union africaine les seuls
ce sont les américains qui ont acquis on
a qui ont peut-être un jeu à jouer si
l'on peut dire dans les futures
négociations qui vont devoir s'installer
parce qu'on ne voit pas comment à bien
mettre pourra se passer de faire revenir
les est il humain dans le jeu au pied
dans le jeu politique et soutient le
premier ministre dont fait référence à
mohammed a reçu le prix nobel de la paix
en 2019
aujourd'hui la donne a semble-t-il bien
changer ce qu'on peut craindre que
l'ethiopie devient une dictature
je pense que ce qui vient de se passer
au tigre à il va montrer que la
dictature n'est pas pour demain
je ne pense pas qu'à bien mais
d'aujourd'hui va devoir continuer sur la
même ligne de conduite qu'il a fait
depuis trois ans malgré les résultats
des élections qui vont être donné d'ici
peu de temps
ces résultats des élections vont être
entachée par ce que vous avez donné
comme événement c'est à dire que la
prise de mekele par les tigres est une
région état qui renaît son père
donc forcément ils vont se battre
jusqu'au bout ne serait ce que pour
retrouver la conformité de leurs
territoires de leur politique si l'on
peut dire et il va falloir qu'il va
falloir qu'il joue dans le jeu politique
éthiopiens et des toute l'astuce et
l'intelligence d'abia main doit être
décidé de faire revenir à la table des
discussions si l'on peut dire parce
qu'il est obligé de les faire venir
ils n'ont pas voté pour les élections
qui se sont déroulées il ya quelques
jours
et là il va bien falloir tenir compte 6
% la population si non négligeable
surtout que je permets de vous rappeler
que c'est grâce aux tigres et un que ben
keith tout est tombé en 1991
donc oui les tigres rien ont une part
importante dans l'histoire de l'équipe i
will self donc a été décrété jusqu'en
octobre est ce qu'elle sera respectée
selon vous à mon avis ce que vont faire
les tigres et dans un premier temps
c'est reconfigurer la totalité du
territoire à leurs mains c'est à dire
qu'ils ont expulsé les erythréens
l'armée mexicaine et les amarres et donc
reprendre la totalité de leur territoire
dire que même ce que les amarres à leur
ont volé si l'on peut dire au début du
conflit en novembre
ils vont le récupérer donc ça la
première instance ce sera là après ce
serait de revenir en fonction de ce que
le gouvernement fédéral va décider de
revenir sur un jeu politique au sein de
l'équipe i donc l'avenir n'est pas rose
on peut dire on est parti pour une
longue période d'instabilité à mon avis
bien triste aujourd'hui mais à bien
mettre va devoir baisser un petit peu sa
garde il ne veut absolument pas discuté
avec le front de libération des tigres
or c'est ça va être le seul représentant
dutil de la région est un tigre a donc
affaire qu'il négocie avec eux ils
reviennent en force puisqu'ils seront
incontournables dans les négociations ne
pas oubliez vous disais tout à l'heure
l'alarmé est en déroute le gouvernement
intérimaire est en déroute aussi c'est
quand même sacré humiliation pour
quelqu'un qui avait pronostiqué de
guerre rapide et puissante
merci beaucoup patrick d'avoir été avec
nous
dans le reste de l'actualité le liban
qui suscite de nombreuses convoitises
les projets de reconstruction du port de
beyrouth détruit par l'explosion de
l'été dernier s'accumulent sur le bureau
du gouvernement
dernière proposition en date celle de la
russie hier les ministres des affaires
étrangères américain français saoudiens
ont re appelé aujourd'hui les dirigeants
libanais à surmonter leurs différends
pour résoudre la crise traversée par
leur pays
de son côté la population continue
manifesté pour dénoncer les crises
multiples que traverse le liban théo
combes avec yamina benguigui da tourner
la page
près d'un an après l'accident du port de
beyrouth le liban souhaite reconstruire
les infrastructures endommagées par
l'explosion
un chantier qui promet d'être
gigantesque et qui forcément attise les
convoitises
après l'allemagne la turquie ou encore
la chine c'est de russie qu'une
délégation est arrivée afin de discuter
des projets de reconstruction du port
une visite à laquelle le ministre
libanais des travaux publics s'est
montré sensible
j'ai eu l'honneur aujourd'hui
d'accueillir l'ambassadeur de russie à
la tête d'une délégation d'experts
techniques russe sur plusieurs sujets
liés à l'étude des ports ils ont exprimé
leur volonté de coopérer avec le liban
est d'apporter une aide technique au
port de tripoli et à celui de beyrouth
la délégation passera trois jours au
port de tripoli et trois jours à celui
de beyrouth
elle étudiera la possibilité de
construire de nouveaux silos à grains à
tripoli et à beyrouth après les visites
des installations du port de beyrouth et
de celui de tripoli également concerné
par un programme de rénovation
le promoteur russe s'est déclaré prêt à
soutenir le projet de reconstruction et
avec le soutien de l'ambassade de russie
go tower d'alcool nous sommes prêts à
continuer à soutenir le liban par tous
les moyens disponibles
nous sommes maintenant passés à la
dimension technique du port de tripoli
et nous sommes prêts à voir sur le
terrain ce qui peut être fait de
bayreuth
comme cette entreprise russe plusieurs
conglomérat étrangers cherchent à opérer
au liban arguant de leur volonté d'aider
à reconstruire le pays
c'est le cas de la france emmanuel
macron n'avait pas caché sa volonté de
participer à la restauration du pays du
cèdre
lors de sa visite dans le pays en
septembre dernier à condition que les
libanais procède à une réforme de leur
gouvernance politique
six rendez-vous de fin octobre
ce sur quoi vos dirigeants se sont
engagés n'est pas au rendez vous nous
devons en tirer les conséquences alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
soit rien n'a été fait et ce moment là
c'est clair je devrais dire à la
communauté internationale nous ne
pouvons pas être au rendez-vous de
l'aide au liban mais je devrai aussi
vous expliquer expliquer aux libanais et
aux libanais nous étions prêts à vous
aider vos dirigeants en ont décidé
autrement
il n'y a pas de chèque en blanc un voeu
pieux rester pour le moment sans réponse
cela fait plus de dix mois que le liban
ne dispose pas d'un nouveau gouvernement
une situation dramatique pour la
population libanaise victime d'une crise
politique doublée d'une crise économique
elle multiplie les manifestations et la
contestation s'amplifie
selon l'onu la moitié de la population
vit désormais sous le seuil de pauvreté
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes avec emilie gogh h
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui
extraient musée de la société
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis le graet ci est officiel les
systèmes douaniers étaient compliquées
par la mise en oeuvre du rex it
le vrai sujet c'est celui de faire
dialoguer les douaniers français les
poignées britannique est ce qui
m'inquiète dans le bric site c'est pas
le break 6 et la bureaucratie du brics
comment ça va se passer par exemple pour
l'été qui arrive la côte d'azur verra
peu ou pas d'anglais je suspecte
effectivement le gouvernement
britannique d'essayer de convaincre les
britanniques de rester en grande
bretagne pour faciliter la relance de
l'économie britannique par rapport à la
crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour beaucoup le foot